así
hasta ahora nuestra discusión ha sido en
su mayoría visual y geométrica y eso es
bueno porque así es como piensan
nuestros artistas pero en pixar también
tenemos que crear programas de
computadora y las computadoras piensan
mejor en términos de números ecuaciones
y álgebra así que de alguna manera
tenemos que conectar esos dos mundos el
mundo de las imágenes y geometría y el
mundo de la álgebra de los números y las
ecuaciones de hecho este puente entre
los dos mundos fue una de las cosas que
realmente me atrajeron a los gráficos
por computadora desde el principio me
pareció muy interesante como el álgebra
y la geometría conspiran para crear arte
entonces lo que haremos es desarrollar
una fórmula que nos permita calcular los
puntos con exactitud en una parábola y
esta fórmula nos permitirá escribir
programas de computadora como este que
permite dibujar la parábola sin tener
que dibujar alguna de las líneas de
construcción
nuestro primer paso en la búsqueda de
esta fórmula es generalizar la idea de
promedio o puntos medios a la idea de
promedios ponderados entonces analicemos
nuevamente nuestro segmento de línea ave
pero en lugar de que la computadora
calcula el punto medium supongamos que
quiero calcular un punto en donde ben
tenga el doble de importancia que no hay
nada particularmente especial sobre que
b tenga el doble de importancia que am
es sólo un ejemplo sencillo de un punto
que no es el punto medio entonces en
álgebra podríamos decir que m es una
copia de a más dos copias de pep y
después tenemos que dividir entre tres
para que esto sea un promedio adecuado y
puede escribirlo aún más simple como a
más 2 b entre 3 y ahora podemos
escribirlo en una forma final y de esta
forma final sería un tercio de a porque
observamos que tenemos un 1
implícito antes de am y después tenemos
dos tercios antes de ver entonces me
quedaría dos tercios debe y además
puedes observar que este un tercio más
estos dos tercios es igual a 1 esa es
otra forma de decir que este es un
promedio adecuado entonces esa es el
álgebra ahora echemos un vistazo a la
geometría bueno la geometría dice que la
longitud a m tendrá una razón de dos
tercios respecto a esta longitud mt que
está a una razón de un tercio
ahora observen que el álgebra dice que
los dos tercios están con ver pero la
geometría dice que los dos tercios están
opuestos a b y eso parece un poco raro
en principio pero si lo pensamos un poco
tiene sentido porque si hubiera un gran
peso frente a vélez esperaríamos que
este punto estuviera muy cerca de p ok
pero podemos generalizar esto aún más
déjame reemplazar el dos tercios de aquí
una fracción arbitraria llamada t
entonces la t se queda con la p en
álgebra y ahora para que esto sea un
promedio adecuado necesito poner algo en
frente de a pero si a ese algo le
sumamos temp
entonces eso tendría que ser igual a 1 y
ese algo que cuando le sumamos usted es
uno es la fracción 1 - tema entonces
ahora mi expresión es uno menos temporal
más de por ver esa es el álgebra de esta
situación generalizada y la geometría es
que estos dos tercios van a ser
reemplazados por t mientras que esté un
tercio va a ser reemplazado por uno
menos t
entonces obtengamos un poco de intuición
para esta idea usando este interactivo
aquí tenemos un segmento de línea pero
puedo arrastrarla y podemos ver las
coordenadas de amd y las coordenadas de
b y como acabo de abrir el interactivo
el punto que está calculado es el punto
medio por eso está en la mitad entre a y
b pero ahora puedo desplazar ese punto
hacia donde yo quiera a lo largo de esta
línea y eso corresponde simplemente a
cambiar el valor de t entonces
diferentes valores de temp me dan
diferentes posiciones a lo largo de la
línea en los siguientes ejercicios
tendrán la oportunidad de obtener un
poco de experiencia con la idea de
promedios ponderados